-Our next guest is a
"New York Times" best-selling
author and actor you know
from "The Office."
His new show, "The Premise,"
is streaming now
exclusively on FX on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-I know you want to
make a difference,
and maybe this isn't
how you imagined it,
but this is your chance
to be a hero.
This is your chance to
make a difference,
a big difference,
in a man's life.
Ethan...
this is your shot.
-And, Ethan, you are not
throwing away your shot.
-Please welcome back
to the show B.J. Novak.
♪♪
-Hey.
-Hi, buddy.
-How are you?
-Thanks for being here.
Great to see you, too.
Have to wave?
-[ Laughs ]
-Hi, everybody. Hello.
It's great to see you.
-I asked Nathan this question.
And I know you did some
early stand-up days.
You probably played in some
pretty bad rooms,
as well as far as audiences.
-I have definitely gotten
the kind of silence
that you get
in a room like this.
-Yeah.
-Where did you first do
stand-up in New York?
-The first -- Well, the first
show I ever did was in L.A.
It was the
Hollywood Youth Hostel.
-Okay.
-It was October 10, 2001,
so it wasn't a funny time.
-Right.
-And there weren't a lot of
English speakers in the crowd.
-Gotcha.
-And the guy before me killed.
He did an impression of
Robert De Niro taking a dump.
-Oh, wow.
-Which transcends language
barriers.
And I should have
taken that cue.
And my very
dry, ironic one-liners
about the tragedy that had just
happened did not -- did not
play as I hoped.
And the emcee said sort of the
most crushing thing
to hear after your set.
He said, "Takes a lot of courage
to get up here."
Yeah.
So, yeah, sometimes,
the compliments are more --
-More cutting than,
yeah, the zingers.
Your face is the poster
for your new show.
-Which is also kind of
your face.
-It is.
-Yeah.
-And I'm not going to show a
picture...
-Thank you.
-...of your show, but I'm
pretty certain we almost have
the exact same pose that I had
when I first did this show.
Like, I think, like,
just some version --
-Where's -- which camera do I --
-Yeah, they're right there.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's
a very obnoxious look,
but it's the only way, I guess,
to convey,
"This is kind of a comedy."
-Yep.
-Because just me like that,
you know, it's dramatic,
and...is kind of not it.
But it's not --
Yeah, I don't love it.
-It's -- Did you -- Were you
worried and have you seen yet --
Being in the city,
has it been defaced yet?
-I'm dying for it be defaced.
-Yeah.
-I have not -- That's when
you know you've made it,
when your billboard is defaced.
And I look forward
to it being defaced,
but it's just --
It's been left alone.
-Oh, that's -- Yeah.
-But my plan is to, someday,
star in something
that is just really an
experiment to be defaced.
I have this vision of making
a movie called
"The Invisible Trumpet," and the
poster is me just like this.
-Like, can they resist?
-Yeah, no, it would really be --
I really envision it as
an art contest.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
You would see
what people came up with.
-I wonder if, for a certain
level of graffiti artists,
they might think, "Too easy.
I'm not gonna even do this."
-I mean, yeah, it's sort of
"The New Yorker" caption contest
for, you know,
the defacer community.
Right, 'cause what
would they draw?
Maybe someone would break --
break your heart with
what's in my mouth.
-With some
beautiful piece of art.
-Yeah, or make a statement.
-So, this is an anthology
series -- five episodes.
-Yep.
-It's great.
What I love about it is that
they are like short films.
And I think --
-Well, I would say that
they're like short movies,
because short films suck.
-That's a really --
I like what you're doing here.
I am fully on board with this.
-I think short films --
and I'm sure there are some
beautiful ones out there --
but short films
tend to be elegant meditations
on loss or something like that,
whereas a short movie --
Movies are too long,
in my opinion.
Every movie is too long.
They're like
2 hours and 15 minutes,
and when you check your phone,
it's really like six hours in a
given evening to watch a movie.
And a TV show -- you think of
a TV show as shorter,
but it's even longer, because
you're like 400 episodes behind
everyone if you start the show.
So, to me, a short movie
is really like,
what if you had, like,
a story that had
some comedy and some drama and
was about something interesting
and good actors and you just
made it in half an hour?
And you could watch
an intense little movie,
and then the next one.
So that's why
I wanted to do this show.
-I will say, with all sincerity,
I watched an episode -- because
it was recommended to me.
One of the episodes
is called "Butt Plug."
-Yeah.
-And it is
incredibly dramatic...
-Yep.
-...and also very funny.
But I -- One of
the things I noted is that
when it was over, I could not
remember the last time
I had sort of,
like, uninterrupted,
watched half an hour
without being distracted,
because it did have, like,
the arc of a film...
-Yeah.
-...which was really cool --
and the stakes of a film --
and, yet, at the same time,
I did not feel like a huge chunk
had been out of my day.
-That's exactly
what I'm going for.
And I do love shows
like "Black Mirror"
and "The Twilight Zone,"
but I hadn't --
Those aren't my voice.
My voice is this
very particular brand of comedy
that you find funny
or you don't.
Or you find dramatic
But it's --
You know, the whole goal is,
what are these
intense movies that, like,
aren't weighed down with some,
you know, subplot that kind of
bloats it into 90 minutes?
I like movies,
too, but too long.
-I mean, they're
definitely not going to --
I think the movie community
is not going to think
this was a glowing review
by either of us.
-No. Or the
short-film community.
-Right. Now they're going to
come after us hard.
-Yeah, forget Sundance
for me now.
-You have a great cast.
We saw
Ben Platt, Tracee Ellis Ross.
But a really cool thing --
you got to work with Ed Asner
on maybe his last project
that we're going to
get to see him in.
-Not my fault.
He was really wonderful
and inspiring to work with.
He was, you know, 90 years old.
And he would rest between takes,
which we asked a lot of him.
It was quite a role,
but he wanted to do it.
But he would wake up --
And, you know,
his assistant would gently say,
"It's time" and wake him up.
And we'd feel bad
bringing him back to set,
but once he started,
he would not stop.
He would do improv after improv
and take after take.
And it just shows you that
someone of that level
doing it that long,
you just have to love it.
It's only love
that can make you do that.
-It's a really cool thing.
Finally, "The Office,"
maybe more popular now
than it's ever been.
-I know. Wow.
-You Instagrammed this
the other day and said --
What was your phrasing?
"If you know..."
-Yeah, that sentence, IYKYK --
"If you know, you know."
I always have to,
like, sound it out in my head.
-This was a drink
that someone sent over to you.
-Yes, this is,
I think, a 7 and 7
with seven maraschino cherries
and sugar on the rim --
blend it, if you can --
which was what
my character ordered for
Mindy Kaling's character
on an "Office" episode
that I forgot long ago, because
it was like 15 years ago,
but it's fresh in
many people's minds.
And this was just last night.
-That is a very cool thing,
the long tale of love
for that show.
-Yeah, but the drink
I don't recommend.
-New episodes of "The Premise"
are available Thursdays
exclusively on FX on Hulu.